ouais on est on est là pour rappeler
tout ce qui a dit monsieur macron et
différents ministres du gouvernement
pendant le confinement pour saluer le
travail des personnels soignants et
administratifs des hôpitaux publics et
lui a rappelé que les paroles c'est bien
mais les actes c'est mieux et pour
l'instant à part une médaille savais
même pas en chocolat d'ailleurs il n'ya
pas grand-chose d'annoncer y compris au
niveau du ségur qui a débuté maintenant
depuis quinze jours donc oui la santé
c'est pas un coup c'est un
investissement et ça concerne tout le
monde
on veut ni médaille ni cérémonies ni rtt
c'est à dire que là on n'est pas des
jobs
on a fait notre travail dans des
situations que le gouvernement nous a
mis en difficulté qu'on connaissait pas
est ce que nous on appelle un peu
vulgairement en mode dégradé
on réclame 300 euros pour tous et pour
tous tous les hospitaliers tout de suite
on réclame des effectifs pour soigner la
population dans des conditions
acceptables est normal et on demande la
réouverture des 10 et l'arrêt des
fermetures délié on a vu que nos lacs
dans le cadre de la crise qu vide et ben
les lits étaient importants pour qu'on
en charge la population et que le fait
d'en avoir fermé énormément ben ça fait
qu'on était en difficulté enfin médaille
en chocolat c'est pas le truc
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est d'avoir
des salaires décents
là on a sorti on a sorti des affiches
qui sont extrêmement parlante la perte
de pouvoir d'achat entre 1980 et 2000 20
par rapport à combien ont commencé en
début de carrière par rapport au smig et
elle vous smic et combien on en est
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui terminait
à qui commençait à 1,2 smic et qui
terminait à 1,9
aujourd'hui il commence au smic et
termine à 1,3 donc on a perdu énormément
d'argent en jeu